for Tyson now let me ask you guys this
who's interested in Tyson versus usyk
now there is no hype on that fight it
was the only fight I wanted to see I
want to see Tyson vers Francis that's
the fight I want to see Francis vers
Wilder I want to see Francis versus
freaking Anthony Joshua Francis hey kids
is a boxer now hey pfl take a hike I
know you guys own his MMA rights or
whatever and you have to allow him to do
this be cool man you got to be cool
France is a boxer now he can make
ungodly money just boxing pfl who are
you going to give him where he's going
to make $30 million in MMA go ahead name
a single fighter you can pull from any
roster where he can make the same money
get the same attraction as he could in a
Tyson Fury rematch a Wilder fight an
Anthony Joshua fight he is a boxer now
that's what he is